e
e e
house version looked at an opportunity
to have a couple of expert um lawyers
available and thought it was time to
overhaul the
laws on Ed on education which had some
contradictions and some some other
problems with them that had been brought
up the bill only came to finance because
it was just a matter of uh raising
$100,000 to hire the expert to do this
and so it passed the house and passed it
passed the finance committee pass the
house went to the
Senate the Senate put all sorts of stuff
on it that should have gone to an
education committee it made it permanent
in in law and it had things which I
think are never called for in law where
it says uh I you know any other person
they think should be added on a
commission that's not good law that's
not good language they're not on the
commission they are on advisory P
different than the commission either way
it's in law with anybody can be added I
don't like that language I don't like
the Senate version at
all what can you do to change
it thank you Mr chairman but just point
out that it's not permanent there's a
prospective repeal in 2026 so the
Senate gave the commission two years to
do the recodification and then repeal
the commission
and in addition to all that um the rsas
right now clearly state that uh
recodification is the purview of the OS
people and not you you don't want the
fox Garden the hen house and that's what
your bill did is it gave money to uh
education but didn't give anything to ol
s and Os according with the existing
state law is supposed to be in charge of
recodification
I didn't fight given the money to
education but I certainly added the the
money to uh OS so that they can hire
hopefully one of their
recent uh Alum we'll put it that way
those were the people we were targeting
to to help uh but they should not be
reporting to the Department of Ed they
should be reporting to Mr Alec
onas Mr chairman representative em uh we
had the public hearing on this uh as it
were and it started it was an idea that
said why don't we just
identify the areas where there's direct
conflict it wasn't re Rec codify the
whole title 15 it was
just in our committee we kept hearing
little well this and this says this and
this one says says that that's all we
were interested in and that's Hill's
original bill was just to do minor
identification and then have OSS right
fixes as you were but this guy it got
bigger I mean it turned into a whole
reification the whole thing so I think
the
intent at least in that in the uh
sponsor's mind and in in division two
was small fixes not entire
rewrites uh just I identify that the
glitches that are currently exist so I
think part of us perspective on what
what we're trying to do
here well when you actually look at
who's on the commission you've got one
Senator you got two house members you've
got the uh
commissioner and then you've got
legislative services and Department of
Justice uh I'm reading line S through
11 all right 1 through
4 and when we get down to B that starts
the advisory panel and just like
anything else they don't have a vote
they don't but they should
be you know named for consistency sake
and that's what we did and in six the
one you object to the most chairman is
that you know it is the advisory
committee uh who is going to say they
are or they aren't part of the advisory
I should say it's going to be the
commission that says they they do or
don't need
them I mean well actually it's going to
be the
legislature in this the way it's written
well no any any changes would have to be
legislation the legislation here gives
them the permission uh this is line 22
in the Senate version uh
six it says additional individuals or
organizations uh the commission deems
relevant uh to its study I've never seen
that before in a
commission
but they're not adding them to the
commission they're adding them to this
advisory panel which are not members of
the commission represent Heath so we
know there are a lot of conflicts um
just charter schools in one section can
get building Aid in another section they
can't get building it in and I'm sure
there are lots of other places we need
somebody to identify the
conflix I don't think it's a bad idea to
have somebody look at what the work that
they've done my preference would be that
we come up with a document that
ultimately becomes a bill that has to go
through the legislature saying these are
the changes we're going to make so that
in fact there's we take the political
out of it
um and just have a working document that
goes into our laws that works for
everybody because right now there it's
confusing being a former Deputy
Commissioner working with the the law
book is not an easy thing to do and I
think Caitlyn can attest to why the
department came forward and asked for us
to do this um I don't have a problem
with a group of people working in advis
like a commission to look at what the
work that the attorney's doing I'd love
to see Anthony or somebody like Anthony
do this work um but I can't see the
commission would take forever for the
commission it would be monotonous it
would be like going line by line by line
it would be horrible I I can't even
imagine how monotonous that work would
be but if we had somebody first do the
work and then have somebody a group of
people come
together certainly the vision that I had
uh was that
uh between education and the people in
OSS they would come up with the
recommendations and when there was a
conflict like you say in many places you
know building Aid is one they can and
they can't uh that they then would go to
the commission and the commission would
say the way we want the new bill that is
going to come from this drafted is and
that would come from those Commission
members the senator the two house
members the commissioner of Ed and
ol that's what the vision you've taken a
clean process and made it political I
object I disagree it appears that way to
me Senator thank you Mr chairman I don't
I don't read the
commission as actually having to to
do the drafting it's more they would
introduce they would agree to changes my
notes from the public Hearing in the
Senate is that this would end up this
could be A500 page Bill to rec
codify all those sections of Statute it
is O s's responsibility under RSA 17A
um it's not an executive
branch
function but neither all has nor
education
has the resources right now which is why
we put the
$100,000 for each of them for attorneys
and gave them an extra year
but I don't I don't read it as these
three legis lers plus the commissioner
of education and the director of os
that's sitting around and saying okay
let's let's change this this word here I
I read it as this would be the
recommendation of the
lawyers with input from The Advisory
Board and it would be a commission
recommending recodification a on the
statutes which hasn't been done for like
50 years like ever okay
long longer than Lou alesandro has been
in the legislature so I think Mr Senator
gray I think that's why the
Senate yeah made the decision it
did representative muray thank you U my
understanding was that um this is a very
tedious job which one competent person
could do um I don't think that there's a
lot of back and forth about is there is
this a conflict or not either it is or
it isn't and I think we have a lawyer
who can put forth to say that and I
didn't Envision a lot of back and forth
with the commissioner and Advisory board
but that this person would do the job
and submit a report um perhaps you know
to that commission at when it's done but
it seemed like it would just be back and
forth it be the never ending badminton
gain if we had to keep going back and
forth so I would see this person hired
hopefully I guess you know some people
and I'm sure um doe has people who can
go through this find the issues and then
come back and present it to us that's
kind of how I saw it and then from there
we would construct bills or do what have
to be done but I agree it would be a
lengthy
submission and it would probably be
start in the department of of the
committee on education yes and they
would probably be looking at these
things and some of them they probably
brought up through the years obviously
this the uh commission the chairman of
education is saying they've got to split
the bill up split the committee up it's
just too many bills I think aund and
something oh they're awful this year oh
114 the difference yes yeah the
difference between my vision and your
vision is that what would go to the
education committee would be a bill that
was ready to be introduced and to get to
there then the commission would be the
ones that would make the decision of
again we'll go back to the funding they
would say okay we want to go in this
direction and
those five individuals uh yeah would be
the ones that would give us you know the
rudder orders for that and say yes we
want to be able to fund uh Charter
Schools building
okay and then that would that would
influence where the lawyers went echoing
representative Murray too much back and
forth almost every every decision you
make has got to be discussed rather than
saying okay here's the first 200 Pages
here's what we've come up with as the
worst Parts what do you think and then
go on to the next few hundred pages and
like that rather than go back and forth
every little change so um would it be
amenable to have this one person produce
the document and have your commission
look at it at the end
um when you made the comment about
building aid for Charter Schools yes or
no it's already we already have laws
about it the question is which one and
this lawyer would come back to say this
is the current status of this particular
part of education and in that document
that this lawyer or whoever would put
together um that's where we would look
to see oh I didn't know that this was
the current law or you know perhaps we
all should have but you've seen the book
um and to make their recommendations
from that based on that because it
shouldn't be it shouldn't be debatable
either it's the RSA or it's not and it's
looking to see what is most what it is
most um most current and what do we need
to do with it and seems you know the
commission can look at that at the end
and then send it off to education also
you've got a lot of experts on education
in the Senate and in the house and a lot
of the people I think that you're
referring to uh would show up to
testify but somebody has to do the work
first you know that's right you know
we're
we're making a a a mountain out of this
moh okay you have
that representative that is
not and when you're ready when you're
ready to come back right now the Senate
is going to recess and when you're ready
to speak civil we'll be back tell me
when you are I am not going to agree to
any part of the Senate
bill then what I just heard the chair
say is that you are not willing to
change and the Senate position right now
is that what you've put in front of us
is unworkable and we cannot agreed
correct the bill dies the bill
dies thank you Caitlyn did you feel
strongly that it should
pass
e
e e